[Music]
analyzing data and putting it to work
for your business or organization is an
essential skill for executives today
join the new age of leaders and
understand how best you can use
analytics in this business analytics
program
hi i'm ramesh and banandam
associate professor
department of management studies i
turkey
welcome to the business analytics for
the strategic decision making program
by iit roorkee in collaboration with
simply learn
iit roorkee
ranks among the best technological
institutions in the world
and has played a vital role in higher
tech education engineering and research
in its 175 years of existence fast track
your career in business analytics
in just six months by mastering the most
in demand skills techniques and tools
master key skills like r programming
descriptive analytic predictive
analytics prescriptive analytics linear
and logistics regression supervised
learning unsupervised learning
classification and clustering decision
trees random force data visualization
and more
some key features of this program are
program completion certificate from the
prestigious indian instruct technology
live online master classes
and state of art curriculum designed and
delivered by iit roorkee professors
real world applications of analytics
across multiple domains and sectors
industry insights through master classes
by specialists from ibm
practical exposure
through hands-on projects
and a capstone
industry relevant
case-based learning
specially designed for mid to senior
level managers and c-suite executives
this program will easily fit into your
budget and schedule
you can access all aspects of the
program from your home or office and the
cost for the same is just a fraction of
the tuition fees and expenses of an
equivalent on-campus program
what are you waiting for
get in touch with one of our learning
advisors who will walk you through the
application process